originally I was born out in Hawaii
actually I moved out here probably five
years old Big Island kiosk owner mom was
from Alaska you know I got tired of snow
one day and just took off too you know
how opposites you know then my dad out
there yeah
so I grew up out there for a little bit
kinda remember some of it and mainly
like my pictures and whatnot but you
know they were still pretty racist
towards white people a lot you know so
my mom yeah yeah my mom had a lot of
trouble finding work out there so I mean
after about five years of that she kind
of got sick of it and decided yeah I
moved to California
oh so you been out in Hawaii yeah oh
yeah how these you know they did not
like that for a bit and it's a little
bit more calm down now but back then
they were just they were all over it and
so once we moved out here pretty much
little family or immediate family picked
up moving out here to California you
know that's all here and there but I
grew up mainly out in Santa Clarita you
know kind of I guess the suburbs you
know spend most my high school career
out there like you know doing the whole
football sports thing you know I'm had a
lot of like rich white friends I guess
you know which was kind of cool for a
bit you know but that's how I kind of
got I guess introduced into a lot of
drugs you know the party scene isn't
that kind of spending like every moment
I got trying to hang out and get high
basically after that lost the house out
there we somehow ended up out Lancaster
with my mom that all ended up being kind
of a a burn I hated Lancaster there's so
many just like just nothing out there
but so and I bet at that time I was
already kind of addicted to heroin oh
yeah I mean I've been doing heroin since
I was 17 years old
you know I'm 30 now I'm actually not
doing heroin anymore it's kind of
advanced to fentanyl but that's we can
get into that little bit later yeah so
when I got out Lancaster and my means of
supporting myself as much were gone
because I used to grow and sell pot for
a few years I didn't have the clientele
anymore out in Lancaster so I had to
figure something else out
so I picked up and moved myself down to
the valley with a friend of mine started
basically selling heroin you know
jumping around Airbnb you know for about
a month or two at a time you know here
there here there and just like kind of
selling drugs basically
I met up with a girl down there ended up
getting to a relationship and basically
about 24 close to being 25 she was about
30 and we got rested you know I already
had a couple little run-ins with the law
so like it all of it was basically
possessions and whatnot so I had a
little rap sheet of like you know I'm a
drug user so when I got arrested for
basically she got arrested and got
caught up by selling to an undercover
you know so it was all her doing it I
was just there and by basically meeting
up with our drug dealer and then her
middleman in a sack because there was
three parties involved they were allowed
to charge us with a conspiracy of sales
you know luckily they only charged me
was about six months I had to do flat
time you know and I had six months in
jail it's probably long as I've ever had
to do in jail just a couple like before
that month here maybe a couple days we
you know but I'd always get out but this
time was six months and I was just gonna
be that's it six months no time off
nothing and basically was still with the
girl she only got off with about a
couple days maybe a week time served
because it was the first time she ever
got caught doing anything like that
first time she ever got caught doing
anything I guess so the judge kind of
just let her off easy me I had a little
rap sheet I was thinking about so there
say okay well you know you didn't do
anything but at the same time you're
looking more guilty than you seem so
threw the book at me and that gave me as
much time as they could happen every six
months which was it too too gnarly or
anything but you know once you get to
about a couple months in there you kind
of get a little stir-crazy but did that
and got out so I decided to get back out
of Lancaster with my mom figure
maybe I can do this and I got already
gotten clean jail pretty much which is
okay I can I can handle I can say nobody
around
just whatever well the girls still
around so immediately after I got out I
was backing into drugs yeah yep and a
few months later that's actually when I
got into my motorcycle accident and
basically lost my hand I was in the
hospital for about a week that was all a
medic out so like they didn't really
that actually is a funny like kind of
little thing I always think about too
because basically when it happened I'd
seen it all I was conscious so like my
hand was pretty much severed you know
barely hanging on but ligament or two
and I mean I'm talking about artery was
cut like I'm bleeding in a pool of blood
just maybe a slap of skin and like the
ligament that connects my thumb and my
finger net finger like I could barely do
that and that only yeah I was just
hanging there just cannot it was I
couldn't feel it because I was in shock
you know I just flew 30 yards in it like
you know in the air and tumbled actually
all my way to go pick up a sack and you
know funny enough and basically they
took me to the hospital
and they kind of showed me out as fast
as they could because I was you know on
medi-cal shipped me off to San
Bernardino which actually had a physical
therapy rehab that I stayed in about
three weeks about four weeks or
something like that because I mean I
just wanted to get out of there because
not only was that I wasn't really dope
sick you know from not having any dope
because they had me on percocets
I was in the hospital to have my own
gelada and so but I had like the whole
mental issue of everything you know the
depression was kicking in
and I call that restlessness and I'm I'm
broken kneecap severed hand like you
know I was pretty messed up so like I
couldn't really walk around I was in
wheelchair and I had to have assistance
getting out of bed into a wheelchair
like you know and so that restlessness
was killing me you know like it's just
stuck in a bed you know nobody that I
knew was around me so the depression
just got crazier and crazier now just
like I need to get out of here so I mean
I pushed to basically get out of there
as fast as I could and I'm talking I
didn't even get home when I like when I
got out of there was July 4th 2015 I
think maybe 2014 July 4th and I didn't
even get home yet I had my mom stop off
somewhere where I knew I could figure I
called my drug dealer from the rehab I
was like hey you know what's up is that
where you been at man like what happened
that day you were supposed to come get
that sack and I'm like you'll never
guess bro I got a [ __ ] bad motorcycle
accident at the hospital you know but
hey I don't got cash I had my EBT card
on me let's work something out like you
know before I even got home I said I had
my mom stop off somewhere that I knew I
could meet him and I just I got a
saccharide and I was back on it already
so I mean I'm down in percocets
you know back at home they gave me they
were giving me ambien to go to sleep and
[ __ ] and I was taking up my candy and
like that kind of like went off a little
bit and I kind of was using the the
accident to make me kind of squeeze some
money on my mom at the time you know a
Christian I was telling you know I ran
out of my prescription you know and we
tried getting another basically going to
a clinic or I forgot how we were trying
to get another prescription for me but
you know basically because I'd ran
through the original once too fast you
know I couldn't fill the new one
you know so I wasn't able to get it
filled and also you know how we can do
this so I started telling my mom like oh
well I know somebody who's got these
pills like you know I can go pick up
some of them like so that came like the
new daily like you know I wasn't even
having a trade pills anymore I was just
getting money to do this now and
basically just waiting for my settlement
to come through you know because the
accident you know it wasn't my fault at
all a car didn't see me and they turned
out right in front of me you know I
don't look right into it you know and I
was going about 80 miles an hour yeah
getting pills I was telling let's tell
him I was getting the pills but I was
using it for heroin obviously you know
because I mean I don't know if you to
know too much about a chemical
dependency and like you know heroin but
once you get to that point of an opiate
you know lesser ones don't work
obviously you know so I can I can sit
there all day long and take as many
dripped like pills as I want but because
the Aaron it's not gonna do too much you
know so obviously I was spending the
money on heroin and basically at that
point just waiting for my cash flow let
him through
you know I hadn't uh I had a lawsuit
going with basically the drivers
insurance you know just kind of you know
trying to get money to just take care of
myself for a little bit you know which
obviously didn't work out that well it
went through I you know got my
settlement because I didn't actually
have active insurance on my motorcycle
at the time it kind of [ __ ] me pretty
bad and I was only able to get like a
hundred grand of the accident which
dirty of it 30,000 won so my turn
and because I was on médicale I don't
know if you know too much about
médicale and how they do all that
[ __ ] but I had to pay back some of
you know my medical bills and which was
up to about twenty four thousand dollars
okay for that so I mean I got fifty or
so you know fifty seven thirty six
thousand dollars from that yeah you know
and a lot of people oh yeah I'd do that
in a heartbeat but a lot of people don't
really realize like what comes with that
you know like I was right-handed when
this happened you know obviously you
know I'm left-handed now I used to be a
little bit ambidextrous you know when I
was back my stoner days I thought like
it was funny to do [ __ ] left-handed so I
mean I write better now my left hand
that I ever did was my right yeah so
it's Bill lists I spent a lot of time
trying to do that no to you know
[ __ ] I I bought a house or I started
running I started more using a house
basically my mom moved out with her
boyfriend so I took over the lease on
that house and slowly but surely that
house became a Trap House my chest here
pretty much I mean there was so many
drugs going in and out of it my friends
were just like staying here and their
girlfriend at the time was living and
yes it went fast you know all the drugs
and you know I was getting probably
seven thousand dollars every two weeks
on checks from my attorneys and I mean
I'm talking that by the two weeks was
coming up I was already waiting for that
next check come through and I mean a lot
of people don't realize realize how fast
you can spend money but it goes but ever
since then like soon as I had kind of
lost that house ice that's when I guess
extent of like kind of my second or
third round of being homeless kind of
started you know when I was living in
the valley you know selling heroin my
money my friends money kind of ran out
Aaron B&Bs kind of stopped so basically
we started living in the car or I
started with my girlfriend her car you
know we were renting u-hauls kind of
sleeping at those for a bit you know so
I was already kind of used to you know
sleeping outside the drugs helped you
know it wasn't like I was dealing with
too much outside I was like okay nodding
off here there wasn't that bad but
Lancaster the weather is just so extreme
yeah cold as hell at night and this time
it was just about to be wintertime
winter time was just ending so I was
freezing my ass off out there and as
soon as basically summertime started to
roll around me and the girlfriend were
trying to
basically get sober in a sense you know
try and do it together
I hope that whole deal so I came out to
my sister's house down over here are my
sister's apartment off the Expo Line
actually she used to live off the
Lausanne again Jefferson it's a pretty
nice area you know and our plan was like
you know get sober and then figure it
out go to rehab and do that or you know
figure something else out so we're out
here for about a week and you know
medical medically you know we did it
with likes boxing and subutex like you
know so it was pretty clean it wasn't
too bad you know except for the mental
part of everything and just about that
one that week started ending up you know
she got a little restless and basically
made up an excuse to kind of turn up
back out in Lancaster and being the
idiot I am you know I followed her and
went back out there and start using
again you know so after that I got stuck
back out in Lancaster and I was doing
the whole homeless thing kind of like
stopping by my mom's you know like kind
of sleep in your car it's cold out here
and I charged my phone my all that
[ __ ] you know I'm just realizing how
like slowly I'm [ __ ] killing my mom
with all this [ __ ] and I never tried
to ask to stay at her place with her
boyfriend because her Walkman was an
ex-addict you know he used to do I think
crack and you know basically was
drinking a lot so I wasn't trying to
bring my problems over to his house you
know because I felt like I might lead
him to relapse or something I know how
all that [ __ ] works
I never asked I was like you know I'll
stop by like I'm not gonna not gonna try
and be here and use or anything like
that around you guys so I just stayed
out you know wandering around and
hanging out staying with friends here
and there
and she was getting pretty tired of it
so I mean at that point I was like hi
well that's that's trying it so it's
gonna do something to do this so I got
myself into acting rehab out there right
right before Palmdale on like the 14 I
made it about two days because they
don't actually do you talk to you there
they want you to be clean before you
show up yeah so I went in there with
fake piss and some drugs trying to just
okay I'm gonna win myself up and up stay
here and work it out that way
well somebody ended up saying something
or whatever and you know I got busted
after like two or three days being there
and got kicked out which I don't really
care I was like whatever
I'm gonna call my girlfriend I figure
something else out after a couple weeks
or a couple months I'm just like doing
the whole homeless again we're basically
my mom called me and told me that I got
you a place to go in detox on Monday so
show up or not but that's all you so I
parted my ass off that weekend you know
had some drugs left over and I went
detox down in Pomona at AARC ended up
staying there
detox there for about a week and moves
to the program downstairs and complete
successfully did it for about three
months yeah
I was clean and I was planning with my
counselor there staying there for four
months but just about when the
three-month mark started coming up he
takes me aside and tells me that
basically your application for you know
another month here didn't go through and
you mean you got two days left to hit 90
days and you're gonna get kicked out
basically you know I have no no plan at
this point you know I'm just like back
at step one like oh [ __ ] like what am I
gonna do and I panicked and relapsed you
know and then end up get kicked out of
the program
basically it was tired of telling my mom
that you know I'm doing drugs all this
and that so I couldn't call her anymore
I was breaking my heart just to like try
and tell her these stories like you know
asking for money or anything like that
so I just like kind of at that point
decided we'll only help I'm gonna use I
might as well just go somewhere where
it's kind of familiar and I can kind of
get away with just being homeless you
know so I came down to skid row you know
luckily I kind of a month prior ran into
somebody I'm you down here
I actually Quinn's daily used to sell
him drugs Lancaster and I ran into him
down here and so that's the first person
I called I told him I gave arrives
looking down on my sister's house I'm
gonna come down to skid row can you help
me set up a tent somewhere like you know
any like safe spot like you know
basically came down here when I
I spent that night in his friend's
apartment and the next morning shipped
off to a separate tent you know that
actually coincidentally was just down
the road right over here
I've actually been down over here in
this little area for about a year now
pretty much is doing it you know I'm
just kind of hustling up where I can i
party I don't know if you've ran into
people telling you about boosting or
anything like that but I mean yeah yeah
so I mean I don't like to get referred
to it as that I mean I kind of tell
people sometimes I'm in a product
redistribution so I mean you know it's
quite lucrative you know some of these
uh pices down here you know down here in
MacArthur Park but you know if you if
you know what they want and you can get
away with getting enough bit you know
you can buy the world these days you
know but pretty much just I've been
doing that selling drugs you know I've
had a couple offers to be selling myself
and I just cannot do that and it's all
from men too and I'm not gay so this is
like
yeah is it you would you be surprised
sometimes I'm not gonna lie to you but
it's just yeah it's honestly a lot of
people tell stories about how bad it is
down here and this and that but you know
I'm one of those people that kind of
just like I look at the brighter sides
of everything and like honestly it's
been bad out here
I I mean I've been pistol-whipped I've
been [ __ ] Gaston my head's like you
know and that's like the worst thing
that's ever happened me down here and
that's all due to something I did
there's nothing I'm just like accident
like that's just something I did you
know being a dumb drug addict you know
and like you know I faced up with I face
I faced it and I'd to handle it but you
know it's not that bad as long as you
can kind of surround yourself with
people who you know at the time I guess
Kara but she seemed care about you you
know because when it comes down to her
all these people do is care about
themselves and if you can kind of learn
and just take care so it's not too bad
you know I've kind of Eli Cohn dug out
my niche and kind of gotten just points
where I can you know take her myself
from people that actually like you know
take care of me and I take care of them
so you know it hasn't been too rough
here
you know this isn't only first year you
know and I haven't had to do it too long
but you know it is getting tiring you
know
that is one thing I will say it is
tiring having to just do the same thing
over and over again you know I haven't
been arrested oh I should I take it back
I've been arrested out here once for
[ __ ] warrants you know I had to go to
jail just in July like right after my
birthday actually my 30th birthday I got
arrested like a day or two you know I
was in jail because old Warren said I
thought were taken care of but it
weren't and that's about it been lucky
enough not to get arrested for
shoplifting or crap like that or you
know possession of drugs but you know
it's it's been okay I guess you know I'm
not too too battered from the whole
experience I guess but you know it kind
of just you know still going you know
kind of still just rolling through it
all
thank you